because I want to see more Studios make
big bold films like this I'll ask you
this as a producer on this uh Margot
what was the key to convincing Mattel
and Warner Brothers to not only give you
the okay on this script but also to give
you guys creative control with your
vision I think my pitch in the green
light meeting was the Studios have
prospered so much when they are brave
enough to pay when they pair a big idea
with a Visionary director and then I
gave a series of examples like dinosaurs
and Spielberg that and that that and
that pretty much naming anything that's
been you know incredible and made a ton
of money for the studio and I was like
and now you've got Barbie and Greta go
wig and I think I told them they'd make
a billion dollars
um which uh you know maybe I was
overselling but we had a movie to make
okay and someone with a Jurassic Park
tattoo everything you just said made all
I do have one I do have one that's kind
of true can you imagine that first
meeting they're like dinosaurs I don't
know I mean yeah but that might turn out
kind of silly and then you know here we
are decades later being like that's the
greatest
Masterpiece uh Ryan for you what is
something about Greta's approach to the
work that you really appreciated and
hope to experience on more films in the
future would like gretis and you know
it's just she's just such a brilliant
person and such an inclusive person and
she's you know she's brilliant but
incapable of being pretentious and she
has this
uh I think what I admire so much about
our work is that she doesn't allow
herself to sort of create a divide
between drama and comedy you know and
she kind of encourages everyone
around her to do the same you know so
you end up sort of I think mining places
that are in the in between
and it feels very you know specific to
her but also something that you can
relate to because it's more like life
one last question for you because I know
when you originally signed on you were
not planning on playing Barbie so who
did you picture in that role and then do
you remember the moment where like you
stood there and thought to yourself like
like no this was the right choice this
role is mine yeah I didn't want whoever
I director was going to be grew up being
the first choice but you know if she had
said no but I didn't want I'll grad our
director to feel pressured to put me in
the role so I was just really upfront
about like I wouldn't be offended in the
slightest he is like we could go to
anyone you know whatever story you want
to tell and whoever you want that to be
I support that like I don't I've got
skin in the game as a producer I don't
have skin in the game as an actor so
like be free with that choice and she
was like shut up I want you to think I
want to write this for you and I was
like you might feel pressured to say
that but and we did that dance for a
while and then eventually I just
accepted that she did want me to play
the role and um and and then she wrote
it and she wrote at me in and she wrote
Ryan in and it was like and names
printed in the script from the get-go
Barbie Marco Ken Ryan Gosling yeah
strong Vision a strong Vision that she
saw about manifesting yeah I don't know
how your movie exists and that makes me
so happy together right now
congratulations thank you